hey everyone welcome back to the demo
stage here at e3 2017 joining Rob and
myself is Danny from Nintendo treehouse
welcome back thank you what are you
bringing with you today
oh here toward the end of day 3 we're
bringing Legend of Zelda breath the wild
though DLC the master Trials right that
noise was Ross know what Rob was very
excited to get a chance to see this
finally so yes we're finally able to
show the master trial is the first of
the two DLC packs that will be available
here we're actually starting sarah's
playing first off-camera which is great
again as always but here we're showing
off the great plateau which people I
remember from the very beginning of the
game but this is in hero mode so it's a
mode you can access from the very
beginning of game you don't have to beat
normal mode to get in here but a lot of
the enemies have been replaced with
instead this used to be Redbook hobble
and there's now blue back hablen right
also their range of ability to hear you
and detect you is much further than it
was but I was gonna say cuz he's far
left you from very far away he also is
his health meters blinking yeah he
actually regenerates health now enemies
regenerate health so you can't do the
little throw bombs run away throw bombs
run away that was my main tag yeah well
you have used before so you can't use as
much anymore no but stairs really good
at this game and she got a bunch of
armaments already so she's pretty
stocked up
yeah they spot you a lot more easily now
than they used to great so it makes it
more challenging for everybody yeah
yeah so how do i how do I access if I'm
playing if I'm playing breath of the
wild do I have to start a new game or
dunno you could say you're starting a
game it will be a separate save file so
be careful you already have before but
you don't have to beat the game okay you
to get there so that's a big help to
have to worry about that it's like a New
Game+ but without having yes just but
yes replaying the game on a harder mode
um there are couples new enemies oh nice
hey guys yeah
so red bow Coughlin's are just not
really present at all is that kind of
the idea mule I bet you'll get to
discourage yourself you might be enemies
in locations but you overall a lot of
the enemies that you were used to seeing
have been upped a bit okay um there's
even a different type of Lionel now as
well Wow challenging that regard as well
so there have a lot going on but what's
cool here so now we're gonna leave the
great plateau but one other cool feature
it's added this one is something called
the travel medallion so you can now
wherever you're staying you actually can
place this travel down where you're
standing now you have a place to fast
travel to that is not a shrine right
anytime you want to that freedom to now
kind of do that and that's a pickup that
you'll have to find on your own right
there's where it lies yeah yes
um and then here's master modes a
different screen even the whole red
screen and colored screen what's going
on here I'll be seen before so we could
chance to see what this mode looks like
so now we're jumping to a different area
to show off another type of enemy that
exists in the game not more than any
more of a mixture there's actually it's
gonna be a platformer that they look a
little different than what you've been
used to seeing in the past right hey so
that's the travel medallion like a your
trap fast shot right there looks pretty
cool yes yep then he goes there's link
oh happy GB it's raining it rains a lot
in Hyrule for some reason mm-hmm you
know I hadn't notice I know but this is
a new thing right here this got the sky
platform that's there now which actually
had the if you notice the even the
enemies that are either actually holding
up recognize that you're there octo
rocks right yes no yeah
so it's Aries doing here she got he's
just stealing this poor guy haha he was
doing nothing to bother her but the one
thing he had going I know and then he's
stuck in this platform the middle of
nowhere but he has a treasure chest
but Sara took away from him oh and now
she's going to be probably really mean
and whoa oh he got a revenge shot off
before you he wasn't going down got a
fight so yeah so that's another that's a
new enemy we have a chance to experience
here and gonna have fun see what else
you can discover in the game as you as
well but the cool thing we've added is
new armor hmm so here we got some new
armor options as well
Oh mom fly that's the one this is the
one I put hissy-fit our eyes it looked
pretty bad at oh man yeah the first one
where his head is completely cutting up
his helmet and yeah up so you look
pretty good oh wow that looks good
and though someone will have different
abilities like this one has Guardian
resistance up and you got them all
matched up together is even the Midna
helmet Oh lovely
yeah little tail back there and there's
even Majora's Mask it's not a majority
eyes cuz link might become really evil
and not just succeed twisted but then
does the Majora's Mask have any kind of
perk like the other we go back to what
is that looks figures like back to the
majora's mask real quick sir perfect
know what the main screen end at
anything in the description wearing a
makes it harder for song enemies to spot
you if sold is rare find you can't be
replaced
oh wow see you reading have to hang on
to it yes something that would be great
for master mode yes yeah for the fear
for the mat for the hero mode you're
going through right now but sarah has a
favorite outfit yeah
tingles time yeah look at that which
gives you it gives you ability to run
faster at night okay cool there's good
on deck so now you can can explore
around as in this king galuf it the
other cool thing though - there is a new
mask as well beyond all that um when
you're trying to find core exceeds which
I know some people there's like 900 to
try to find in this game so it's a lot
to go through but what's cool at this
Korek mask as you're running around when
you get near where a core exceed would
be it starts to kind of jingle and make
us it moves around as well so can i buy
that without having to start like uh in
emote okay is it gonna be a part of like
the main quote the Korg mask yeah so in
my save like right now you'll have to go
you have to find believe so yes yes I
believe so
upgrade my energy I know but he it even
has the same kind of particles of the
Clorox yes ah so what's cool here though
for this is where the quarks yeah I'm
not sure people have gotten this one
themselves but there's these trees here
some us told me about this and I was
like I probably run into these like left
and right I mean I put 300 hours into
the game I was like oh shoot I have
never been IV I didn't I defeated when
we decided to put this as part of the
demo and so I didn't know that was right
there either I'm like oh look couldn't
do fine for myself is also is great
there's so many in this one but now
we're going to head up to another new
part of the games who were going going
to the quark for the quark force the
quark village when the Master Sword was
uh and now we do something called the
sort of the trial of the sword which is
the opportunity to unlock the full
splendor of the Master Sword
but to do so link needs to train his
mind and
body so it's gonna be a bit of a trial
to go through to do this but it does
though so the master short is a pretty
durable sword in the game but has it has
a power level of 30 when you fight
calamity it jumps to 6 e starts glowing
that by that bright glow and has a bit
more powerful they're going on there so
what's gonna happen here this time
though is if you complete this entire
trial that's inside the sword you will
then be able to have it always be at
sixty very beginning awesome um what
Sarah loves to do is she'd love this her
favorite part right here she so this
mask should be going nuts right now
right yeah but Sarah's favorite thing to
do here is to go into this trial by wall
in a tinkle outfit go to the interesting
here is what's gonna happen once we get
inside so remind me is there a
difference between master mode and hero
mode that master master what is the
whole thing they have to hear yeah yeah
oh yeah sorry
that's a new difficulty mode the higher
difficulty is call the master oh no I'm
a-tingle outfit go you lost everything
pretty much yeah like you're even tied
right yes even tied so you lose all your
armor all your weapons all your food um
you can't use your amiibo so you can't
use that to call down treasure chests at
the farm around there it's all just
about your wits about you to go through
that and there'll be about 45 rooms you
have to go through to complete this in
Eventide did you have food with you
without the only thing that you you got
you I can't remember ever top my head
out yeah I think you could find food
pretty easily even too sure yeah not
here all this and there is there is some
food here you can find as well as there
there's gonna be in this one room here
we start right here there are a couple
of blue book ah balloons hanging out
there and they have a steak Sarah loves
to steal their steak just kind of evil
like that they're just having a good
time and Sarah just takes away
everything they have so it's kind of
just rude she's not doing off-screen
yeah dottie
so here after the trial of the sword the
beginning
yes sister room one so she's got a tree
branch really powerful weapon yeah
that's again they are able to nose you
more easily so she's trying to be really
sneaky dude sneaky yeah generally I
throat tree branches pretty quickly but
here that's all she's got right now oh
oh good find
all right she's got two eggs of course
perfect yep
write it investigate yes oh so what
should I do here sneakily is grab all
their weapons up you got this one no
problem good your most [ __ ] and
weaving I love that does that drop table
behind ya yeah it's a great tactic so
now it's tricked oh sure there were they
also get their health back so that's the
other challenge behind all this that she
needs a uni basically able to Zone in on
one person he's a rough heads yeah she's
a fair who she can take out let's write
the help is beginning yes
yeah so maybe one bigger challenge there
in that and weapons break rather weapon
weapon on the ground yes
oh hell for sure I'm on there it is
and she's going with me now they are
super yeah you got one down
all right well more to go if you're
gonna two of my big should you get two
of them yeah yeah it's like if I one of
her best run throughs notice that this
room is hard I mean I've only gotten to
the four through myself so it's not not
out of 40 some 40 oh really and you
didn't even look didn't get past the
four I've only tried a couple times I
okay yes well that's good too
challenging that's the river yes yeah
but she's got that's well good jobs here
hi excellent unlocks the doorway to the
next room should go see what's going on
the next area and see what's happening
there gee so I would imagine the last
trial would be some sort of line but you
have to wait and see I'll keep going as
you go trying to collect anything she
can find right now before she was on to
the next of space thankful every little
bit of health is important right she's
wasting your club I don't know why you
don't use mom so you don't damage your
weapon that's my suggestion so you have
resources are very much something you
want to manage as well as yes go through
the trials and washing it to the second
room so and the rooms aren't always just
all enemy feel there's a puzzle
mechanics behind them as well so it's
not always just one room to have to
worry about she's gonna eat all her food
now alright you might want to are there
like um herbs and stuff scattered around
as well like would you be more inclined
to make like a dish if you could find it
we have nothing to find a fire right I
thought I saw one what was that I'm
sorry make that bigger showing a bit oh
yeah but is there like a pot or anything
like the cookie I'll have to discover
how to discover yeah the second room
she's made it into we'll see how she
goes floor to Ranier say yeah if you're
in point yeah you do a certain point
there is some save point throughout the
trial itself you can get to it over time
but I was gonna say so much and I would
be really frustrating if you go to like
43 and then Devin you're out yeah I've
never seen a menu this empty
yeah again they're still regenerating
their health yeah that's for the channel
but she's done going out which she does
love using the health regen is gonna be
the same for for all enemy types yeah
have a face kind the nose oh just wonder
about his buddy I know Sarah doesn't
care there's something about voc oblems
another end mainly the book goblins I
feel like that they're still there so
humanizing right like I don't know like
I love how they have their like chats
around the campfire I know I can't ninja
time they're all looking to nodding this
I want to know what they are talking
about beating this poor guy
yeah miss Chu Chu is just doing laps it
looks like it's burning everything yeah
in the face very well so far
so they're doing a spin move yeah think
she finished him off she's all she's got
most these guys taken out but she's
running out of weapons I think to
durability still gonna be a big factor
in this I'll be winding arrows call it a
poor fire - she might the explosion
no burn one guy left all right we got
all nice a minute left receipt showing
up at this room Oh got like a minute
left boy have to cut game okay let's oh
that's true there's no thing to mention
to we didn't show um is the hero path is
so that's another feature of a game that
i would even show to here a path earlier
knowing me do not let me show it be sure
to before the second person I think but
yeah you can now see up to approximately
200 hours of your gameplay even even if
y'all ready played supports codes Kitab
with your current save data mm-hmm
tonight shows you everything you've done
on the map like even when you've been
traveling to each location so you can
find those places you've been to versus
the places you might not haven't gone to
yet is there any way to like
specifically mark an area uh with it we
didn't know you've always had the
ability to market I'm on hands like your
pins but I mean like it's his baby you
want to use all your other pins would do
something in here Oh path here but kit
here pet just shows you the path you've
traversed time so yeah you pleasing that
way to want it to right so you can see
areas you have even you haven't seen
because it yeah the map is so dense that
you know any absence of the path can
easily mean something yes does um I
forgot my question regarding the hero
path when you fast travel is there an
indication cuz I feel like it there's a
trace in like kind of like a real time
or speed up it's real time way yeah you
don't watch asleep it'll show you a
little icon group and just ratchet or
somewhere else in the path continues in
the location where jump to so yeah so
can you like is it just like you open
them up and it's all gonna be there or
can gift it like activate it you
activated the kind of fast I was the
whole thing as well this is the first
pack of the DLC there is a second one
coming out as well we haven't as the
date yet this first word comes out June
30th so real soon and the second was
called the champions ballad which is
with the four heroes in the divine peace
and we even showed a me bow off for each
of those yeah well while it felt like I
know I can seem here at the by I don't
get him for free I have to buy him as
well so oh so what's what's been the
most exciting thing about showing off
this DLC because I know people have been
hunkering for yeah he over hunger for a
lot I just people are excited if he were
just excited to see what this is and now
we finally got to reveal at least what
the next one's called the champions
ballot so people are excited for that
I'm just the music I must use fan of the
music of the game so no PC everybody was
excitement that they've been waiting for
this it was only it was
that expensive either was like only $20
to get it yet both the whole season pass
so and it's coming out this year both
pieces so that's the best excitement so
far just seeing people's reaction if you
are still playing the game like I
haven't personally defeated game yet
help me I want to finish everything I'm
trying at all the shrines that's the
problem and if I have this discussion
all the time and there are a couple
people who have not been Ganon yet and
there I feel like there's a point where
you just gotta get it over with just
because it's I want to say that you get
you eventually can get a little
overpowered when you get to them button
guard 'less it's just a it's an
important thing that you just have to
eventually do because I've done it and
I'm still finding myself going back to
the side quests currently right now 300
over 300 hours I'm just knocking out
each side quest and each one just feels
like so big like it important but now
you'll have master mode so you can play
the whole game over again I
intentionally a quest that had combat in
them just like it's like come back to
those and just did like the cooking ones
or making a monster cake for a girl or
whatever it is yeah I love this games
are always good things oh don't you
think you so much for coming back um
we hope you've had a great time on stage
it's been a great time here thank you so
much for having me is your last thing is
my last one I'm done for the day then
the e3 ends in Athens pretty good final
I'm sure we're all it's been a wonderful
show for everybody so great awesome well
thank you again so much for joining us
guys make sure you don't go anywhere
we're going to be cutting to our co-op
stage on the show floor where can you
talking about insomniac spider-mans
don't go anywhere